bonsoir au temps suspends ton vol après
l'heure c'est plus l'heure avant l'heure
c'est pas l'heure
qui veut voyager loin ménage sa montre
bien entendu tout le week-end
l'actualité sera branché sur le cadran
électrique ou non qui vous fera vivre
dimanche une journée de 23 heures mais
qui finalement ne gagnera pas grand
chose sur le temps que nous avons à
vivre ni sur ce que nous faisons du
temps que nous vivons
la raison de ce retour à une vieille
tradition l'heure d'été une tradition
qui n'évoque pas forcément de bons
souvenirs
et bien c'est de mettre nos horloges à
l'heure du soleil pour faire quelques
économies d'énergie et sur ce point il
faut quand même prendre en considération
le scepticisme de l'edf
elle n'attend pas une vraie baisse de la
consommation d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
si on en est aux économies de bouts de
chandelles sur l'énergie il faudrait
expliquer à un certain nombre de
citoyens pourquoi les éclairages publics
restent parfois allumés en plein jour
mais ceci est une autre histoire
que va-t-il se passer en fête dimanche
quand vous dormirez à une heure du matin
il sera brusquement deux heures du matin
si vous regardez votre montre en dormant
que vous aurez perdu une heure de
sommeil et si vous ne la regardez pas ce
sera comme d'habitude ni plus ni moins
quand on essaie de m'expliquer ça à moi
c'est un peu comme quand on veut me
faire comprendre les liens de parenté
entre la petite cousine de la nièce de
la tante berthe et l'oncle du cousin
isidore qui s'était marié en secondes
noces avec le troisième enfant né d'un
troisième lit de la grand mère du
premier nommé je n'y comprends rien ce
que je vois bien c'est que le changement
d'heure va poser des problèmes à la sncf
à l'aviation aux transports en général
et surtout surtout aux travailleurs
frontaliers
nous aurons l'occasion de vous préciser
ces problèmes pendant le week-end
puisque l'équipe de thierry de scitivaux
à préparer là dessus un certain nombre
de reportages en attendant il n'est pas
question de vous laisser sur mon
incompétence
françois de closets va d'abord vous dire
le pourquoi de ce changement d'heure
dimanche et les vraies économies
d'énergie qu'on peut en attendre
michel chevalet vous proposera ensuite
d'un coup d'oeil 1 les conséquences de
ce changement notamment pour nous la
télévision
et principes en matière d'énergie une
économie est aussi intéressante qu'une
production
deuxième principe ce sont les petites
économies qui font les grandes pour
faire marcher ses automobiles la france
doit importer environ 20 millions de
tonnes de pétrole chaque année sinon
découvrez demain en france un gisement
capable de produire ces deux millions de
tonnes par an on importerait plus que 18
millions de tonnes par exemple pour cet
usage
chaque année mais si l'on amélioré de 10
% le rendement des moteurs automobiles
le résultat serait exactement le même
puisqu'il suffirait d'importer 18
millions de tonnes de pétrole par an
pour la circulation dans ce cas précis
bien sûr il faudrait effectuer des
recherches et transformer les moteurs
automobiles
cela coûterait de l'argent mais depuis
que le pétrole est cher
de nombreuses économies sont devenues
rentables avant la crise
quand on ne parlait pas d'économie on
avait prévu que la france consommerait
l'équivalent de 285 millions de tonnes
de pétrole par an en 1985 il est prévu
que cette consommation ne dépassera pas
2 140 millions de tonnes
c'est dire que l'on compte produire
l'équivalent de 45 millions de tonnes
d'économies chaque année dans une
dizaine d'années et dès 1975 ces
économies ont atteint 15 millions de
tonnes
cela bien sûr sans imposer des
restrictions intolérable où trouver ces
économies les gros filon ont vite été
repéré le chauffage par exemple un degré
de moins 4 millions de tonnes de fuel
économiser mais pour la suite
il faut viser des économies qui se
chiffrent en milliers et plus en
millions de tonnes cette semaine même
les cimentiers se sont engagés à
transformer leurs procédés afin
d'économiser 400 mille tonnes de pétrole
par an dans une dizaine d'années se
mettre à l'heure d'été permettra
d'économiser de l'éclairage cela ferait
gagner au maximum 300 milliers de tonnes
de pétrole par an économie modeste mais
gratuite et
on n'a pas de pétrole il ne faut
négliger aucune idée si midi devient une
heure les trains partiront toujours à
l'heure à l'heure de votre montre donc
de ce côté là aucun changement
simplement quelques problèmes pour la
sncf dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
les trains partis samedi à l'heure
arriveront donc en retard dimanche matin
par contre c'est du côté de l'étranger
du côté des frontières que les choses
sont plus épineuse puisque les trains
changent rondeurs en passant la
frontière alors renseignez vous de même
air france a dû résoudre quelques casse
tête d'horaires par exemple paris new
york de 13 heures partira à 13h30 et le
new york paris a tendu à orly se posera
à roissy motif l'aéroport d'orly est
fermée au trafic à partir de 11 heures
le soir
enfin les télévisions vont avoir
quelques problèmes par exemple nous qui
recevons d'habitude à midi les images en
provenance de l'étranger images que nous
vous présentons dans le journal d'yves
mourousi et bien ces images tomberont en
plein journal
et de fait nous risquons de ne pas
pouvoir vous les présenter en direct
enfin les journaux des télévisions
étrangères vont se placer au moment du
film sur la première et la deuxième
chaîne du coup télé luxembourg a avancé
son journal d'une demi-heure de façon à
ce qu'il apparaisse en même temps que le
nôtre comme quoi économie ou pas
concurrence oblige
oui et puis il ya des problèmes des
changes internationaux au point de vue
images qui ne nous avantage pas nous
télévision bien cela dit nous ne
manifestons pas une mauvaise humeur ou
une mauvaise foi tout à fait inutile à
propos de ce changement d'heure beaucoup
diront les avantages de leurs du soleil
comme pendant mon enfance en bretagne
et surtout il apparaît clairement que
les ouvriers les employés qui rentrent
chez eux
bref tous les gens au travail pourront
profiter des longues soirées d'été
notamment pour faire du sport
ah voilà un avantage en effet